[Music]
some celebrities get confused for yeah
other celebrities yeah yeah yeah I mean
I'm in a good place in the sense that
mine is a really nice funny like smart
guy you get confused with Edie hell at
Helm's and I think it confused like
quite a bit the two of us yeah but um
but and and and it happens probably to
the point where if people come up and
say hello like hey it's so nice to you
know see I'm a big fan I'll say my name
and a lot of times they'll be like oh
sorry
Oh like you're The Hangover ah sigh I
wish man I was in The Hangover I'd have
a you know I for the suit you know but
the best was me my buddy Mike went to
the White House Correspondents Dinner
you know there in DC and a young gal and
her father came up and she was like do
you mind if I get a picture at this at
this like after-party thing I was like
no of course not and then she gives her
phone to her dad and and we're staying
next to each other like oh I'm Jason by
the way and she just looks at me just
goes and I go did you think I was
someone else and she goes yes and I go
did you think I was at Helm's from The
Hangover and she goes yeah but it's okay
you look enough like them I was totally
cool I was like good all right cool two
hours later hour later a few more drinks
later whatever she comes up again
it's tough financially can I get another
picture I think we already did this
feels yeah but I know who you are now so
I do it I take the photo away cuz you
know I'm a glutton for punishment we
take it she does it herself and then she
leaves and goes back to her father and I
tell my buddy Mike I go Mike that girl
came up that she just said this and she
doesn't know who you are now where'd she
go you cuz I go she's over here as I'm
pointing to her literally she's showing
the picture to her father her father has
his hand on her back and it slowly moves
down and Pat's her on the butt that's
not no it wasn't her father whenever her
father there it was just an age
inappropriate relationship that I just
the Midwestern boy of me just assumed it
was his daughter no he probably hired
this gal to come in and just you know
make us all feel like [ __ ] for you
know you know a good time is famously at
my family my mom and my parents took my
grant their parents down to like the
Caribbean Rose years ago and my
grandmother was sitting there and she
looked over at the next table and there
was like this really rich old guy
surrounded by like four gorgeous women
in low tops yeah I remember my
grandmother sit at the time look how
nice that man is being to his grandpa
you and your mom's like no no you know
you I've always said your grandma and I
are just innocent folks
you